here we go okay you do things hopefully by now everybody's going to the member site to look at any
new announcements we have supplements subscriptions now and if you subscribe to any of the supplements
you get a 5% discount and you can do every week every two weeks every month every you know two
months whatever you want to do with that subscription but you get a 5% discount this link to direct
link to the zoom calls you guys are all on the zoom call but in case you have to jump on real quick
directly right there some brands some supplement brands like orthomolecular and biotic research no
longer allow any online sales to anybody not just us to anybody so you can google
these products and you find places that are selling them online but orthomolec these companies are
going after those places and try to get them to you know they're some some of these places they're
buying them illegally they might not actually be the real product you know there's all sorts
of things going on with them these companies are just trying to protect their brand so they don't
allow us to sell online and we've just complied with them is trying to do the right thing that's what
their desires are requirements are we still buy from them and frankly private labels from some
of these two but we can't have them on the storm so we can't have invisibly on the store so
anybody can see them so you have to call in your order for those and we can set up subscriptions
for those so just know if I recommend it or you purchase an orthomolecular biotic or any other
product apex energetics is the same way you can't they don't allow online sales i'm sure you used to
me then they completely changed their policy which might smart like to do but if you can't find
a supplement on our store call us and it's that's why when you do cheek swab test most people are
are understanding this and doing this but some of you aren't if you've sent it a cheek swab please
fill out the online request form or you can print it and fill it out and send it with your cheek swab
that's fine but I need that form also if you are doing a one-on-one call with me we call a educational
coaching call you have to complete the form and the box on the membership site that box looks like
this coach call request form that has to be completed for us to legally be able to do these things
so please do that all our courses are available to all of you wonderful people for free and we have
this new one right here product disease at autoimmune course it's the most comprehensive course
that I've created so far you have a loved one has an autoimmune disease you really want to look at
that course it is packed jam packed full of information and I got brought forward and so if you're
having trouble with your right machine make sure that you look at the frequency healing course
too because that has toned forward information on the right all right let's jump to questions
recent PET scan showed tumor growth on some tumors as well as additional triggers my doctor
is prescribing the role that takes inhibitor I have resisted taking medication but I'm concerned
that there is growth can I or should I continue taking their dim along with this medication
if you're taking a role that takes inhibitor should you keep taking dim or dim type product
you know I think so because of the exogenous hormones that you're going to be still exposed to you know
just by living in the plastics the chemicals the pesticides and things like that and all the hormone
products that damage our hormones so I think it's still good to take a natural product that will help
with that also I had thermography done in October it showed no areas of concern also I'm wondering
how can it be if the PET scan this month shows these areas including my thyroid tumors that were not
on this thermography well things can change that quickly from October so that's one of the thing
number two it may suggest that the so what a PET scan picks up a hot spot that doesn't mean
that it's cancer so that means it's a highly metabolic area well it does not mean that they're just
jumping to the conclusion this person has a previous diagnosis of cancer and then they have a hot spot
on the PET scan boy that's metastasis that's many times what it is but the only way to know to know
to know if that is cancerous to do another cell examination of that through what's called a biopsy so
you do another biopsy of that area to make sure that it is cancerous or not so no well I don't
want to do a biopsy so you know I don't know you know what else could I do well
there really isn't any other way to diagnose whether of a possible metastasis this is cancer or not
unless you do a biopsy remember you you wade that out with other findings you're not just looking
at one objective test you're looking at other objective tests and you're
objective findings as well the other spots may be cancer and then the thyroid may not be a cancer
you just don't know you have to testify that I went to a practitioner who did live blood cell
analysis he found bacteria in my blood that could only originate from mouth for the vaginal tract
given the whole body thermogram you did for me in your office showed a hotspot at a bone defect
in my jaw it made sense to take another look at that after the thermogram I did have a cold
beam scan done at a biological dentist they called nothing so he recommended a dentist that would do
an ozone injection at the site to clear out any possible bacteria the research I can find is mostly
about that IV ozone infusions not about localized objections what I found
advises caution because of toxicity to ozone what are your thoughts on the localized injection
I have a consult with the dentist this week I um toxicity to ozone is very very rare um I would
even bring that into consideration doing a localized injection of ozone is is this the wise thing
to do I think your dentist is exactly right this is exactly what should be done so that's what happened
I'm wondering about the correct dosage of highland 951 so highland 951 is a
fermented soy that's used to help dislodge estrogens from the beta estrogen beta receptor
on cell membrane of estrogen and her true positive cancers um I've been taking one teaspoon
of the morning I think I heard it on a zoom one table spoon uh thank you well the correct dosage
I'd test for that so we did a test for it and you're just taking it you know for your own
cautionary sake um I would take it and release the tables for highland recommends you take a half a
bottle to a full bottle per day of course that's the if person is you know got um cancer that's
growing and typically breast cancer that's growing that's what they would recommend um I think you could
get by with a whole lot less than that but um to a teaspoon really I don't think it's gonna do it
you have to take at least a tablespoon uh most of my testing recommendations people have come up
anywhere between five between three table spoons and you know a half a bottle per day so
you need to get out to a dose with any supplement two you use it can be good to like kind of
hyper dose or a period of time usually a week to really saturate your tissues and then you can
back it down to a low dose that's has to do with any supplement you're taking can you please
explain how the rebuilder 300 works that have people had success with it helping with their
apathy from chemo my husband has 17 percent their sense loss in one foot and 27 percent
loss in the other so the the rebuilder is a product that was created to help build back
nerve loss so if there's nerve loss then the rebuilder can be a huge benefit to rebuild that back
on the rebuilder let me pull it up really quick on the rebuilder on the store where it shows the
rebuilder let me pull that off here and I can show you what the unit looks like it looks like a little
tens unit looks like this but you don't hook it up like a tens unit like with pads sticky pads to
your feet you do it where you use rubber pads and you put them into separate a foot bath that has a
split foot bath so not like the foot bath that you use for the ion cleanse but a foot bath that has
a split in it like a like a tool tote and you fill those up with water you put one foot in each one
and then you put the pads one pad in each foot bath and you turn it out it'll feel like a tens unit
this tingle and it's stimulating the nerves at their specific frequency for healing that can really
help a better heal so if there is a I have a a video on exactly how it works on the website so
on the store site you could actually watch a video of me actually trading my staff a number of years
ago and explaining how you have large diameter efforts and small diameter efforts and what
those different nerve fibers do if they function based upon how what they pick up at the receptor
site so an afferent nerve picks up information at a receptor and brings it back to the brain there's
two main different types of these type of nerve fibers and that's what what neuropathy is is
damaged to these nerve fibers so learning about these aetherent large diameter and small diameter
afferent nerves can be beneficial so watch that video that is on the rebuilder store on the site
and that will help you understand how it works will it work with neuropathy with chemo will it
will work with neuropathy with anything but if the person is continuing to do chemo or hasn't worked
on detoxifying chemo it's going to have less benefit so how do you detoxify chemo what are the best
ways to detoxify chemo as it's settled in your feet and in your legs damage the neurons in your
feet and legs is to use the ion pro weight so using the ion pro wave can be helpful to pull that
out of your body and that could be that could be you know a step in healing now you have to rebuild
the nerves and that's where the rebuilder comes in so the rebuilder is a great tool we have used this
probably for 15 years and with really good success I will say that you could get worse before you
get better because as you rebuild these these aetherent nerve fibers you will actually rebuild the small
diameter afferents first and those are your pain fibers so a person could actually feel more pain
oh I've been doing this for a month and my pain has actually gotten worse that's actually a good thing
because what happens is you lose the small diameter afferents first and then you have the large diameter
afferents and so you lose your pain fibers first and then the large diameter afferents are the ones that
carry vibration carry light touch and carry hot and cold and then you'll lose those so then you
basically lose feeling in your feet all together and you'll end up tripping and you'll be falling you
might not have that neuropathy quite so much but you'll be tripping and falling and that's really bad
as you rebuild it you'll rebuild the small diameter afferents first therefore you'll start feeling
pain we've had people complain over the decade of doing this like oh this has gotten worse my pain
is and we have to explain to them that yes you will feel pain first because you're rebuilding those
pathways and then you will once that LDAs come into play then they inhibit the pain and they
explain that to video how your neurology works do my rife programs from May 2020 when I had active
recurrence of my ovarian cancer cover me currently when I don't have any cancer
according to the the oncologist remember just because you have no evidence of disease
according to the neurologist who still want to be running your cancer programs but really have
inflamed gut since December and suffering from extreme um large so if you don't know what
Lars is that's what's called it's low anterior resection syndrome and that is you can end up with the
increased frequency of bowel movements increased urgency all sorts of different things like that
and you so what no your rife programs are not you're not and your current rife programs are
for your ovarian cancer they're not for any bowel issues any gut issues per se so this is where
you may go hey can I get a new rife program for my current symptoms my current disorder my current
whatever I have going on this is where you may want to ask for that so back to the home page of your
uh of the you know the membership home page you're looking at on that home page you're looking down
and see I'm gonna get a cheek swab and I'm going to um you know get ask for rife programs so that's
what you would do so I would suggest you we I would still put in the ovarian cancer programs because
I still think you need to be running that even if you have no evidence of disease but certainly we can
put in other frequencies for other things or I could actually I'll probably just create another
little folder for you um for healthy with whatever else you can point on and that's why you use that for
and let me know I forwarded my recent blood work to you there are several issues but the one I see
right away that I just can't understand are my high cholesterol numbers I'm lowered how can this be
how can I have worse numbers than the month of my diagnosis before I started eating such a good
whole food plant-based diet I gave blood for this test immediately followed five day fast I broke
my fast after the draw during which time I also had COVID I went for the test as soon as I was able
after quarantine could that affect my cholesterol numbers um I don't think
having a viral infection of any kind would have affected your cholesterol numbers what can
so let's talk about what can increase a person's cholesterol numbers what is cholesterol so cholesterol
is a fact that is made in your liver so to be honest 97% at least of your circulating cholesterol
in your blood is made in your liver it's not from your diet so can diet affect cholesterol well yes
if I eat a diet that damages my liver like full of chemicals and and you know additives and
flavorings and toxins that's going to put a lot of stress on my liver and I will actually create
more cholesterol in order to help lubricate my liver among other things so I will have an elevated
cholesterol so um what else could cause elevated cholesterol I'm not eating it kind of stuff I've
cleaned up this person saying they cleaned up their diet they're eating a whole food diet they're doing
so many things you know right how in the world could I have elevated cholesterol well there's other
reasons as well so first of all we have to deflate what elevated cholesterol is what I went to school
of course I'm an old guy but when I went to school 225 was a normal cholesterol level and anything
above 225 was considered elevated cholesterol then it dropped out to 200 then it dropped out to 180
why is that because 225 is dangerous now no I don't think so I think it's because they have this
wonderful drug where they make 80 million dollars a year selling that can lower your cholesterol levels
well it's a wonderful drug to lower your cholesterol levels but it damages your liver it causes all
sorts of problems so you don't want to be a liver tour or a statin drug in my opinion now is there a
time that that might be appropriate if a person's cholesterol is over 300 or 400 or something like that
maybe if you can't deal with it with some natural means there are some natural cholesterol lowering
things and I'm pretty sure I wrote multiple blog posts on this so do look in the blog up there at the
thing about cholesterol levels but so elevated cholesterol can be so you do want to look at possibly
doing some liver cleansing you know ask yourself you know first of all is is it way over 250
is it over 300 to me if you have a cholesterol of 280 it's still not something that you should really
be concerned with if you have a cholesterol of 325 then maybe yeah then I think you need to start making
some interventions and normally I would start with dietary interventions which doesn't have to be done
in this case but you could do some other natural things to help with decreasing cholesterol
I don't think having COVID can is going to really affect cholesterol levels very much
possibly fasting I have to look that up whether fasting can increase cholesterol for a short time
it don't have the answer to that I will look after you know tomorrow or something to make sure that
I've updated that blog post about cholesterol we used to use a product by
fourth of a lecture they're called lipitor that was very good at lowering cholesterol that was
very beneficial for people to keep it healthy cholesterol right now I stopped my beds in February
I grant some hormone shots the tumor had shrunk at half on my CT scan and the last week my tumor
seems to be coming to the surface and having more sensations with it also the lip note under my arm
seems more flamed I know this is a good thing but it that it's coming to the surface but is there
something I can do to keep it a rupting not sure that's the right word but great kids for the skin
they'll call it a said that the skin is getting thin and to watch it carefully also in my last
cheeks while you said to take too levity should I try to increase this to four or stay on two
you know I would stay on two yeah there's positives and negatives in the
tumor coming out of the skin and breaking through the skin this person I'd ask that if you could
send me some pictures and we should probably have a private conversation about this that would be the
best thing to do I had a friend introduced me to taking wheat germ wheat germ and wheat germ seed
and grinding it to use and immediately in threads and muffins could this process be okay to use wheat
flour that we can buy in the store contains gluten but is this okay sour since it's not the process
well it all has to do with you know gluten tends not to be a driver of cancer
but gluten is the most common food sensitivity so if you have antibodies to any of the
glee added peptides then this is not acceptable but I don't know so how do you know how do you
don't we have antibodies to the glee added peptides the only way to really do that is to run a
Cyrex test so Cyrex array reacts I think would be the right one to use hey where could you learn
about that though on the new course product disease in autoimmune you will find enough information to
gain yourself with autoimmune disease and antibodies to food and to peptides of different proteins
like pliantic one of the latter I didn't if you didn't have any of these antibodies to pliantic
peptides should be just fine to use you may want to get some the type of grain wheat that you
might want to get is chemit you can buy chemit flour chemit is an ancient grade wheat I don't know
if you can get chemit seed you'll have to investigate that but do a search on chemit flour this is
we've had people that have had antibodies to glee added but they can actually eat chemit flour
you have to make it as a cookbook that you can get chemit flour cookbook you have to
your bread recipes and muffin recipes have to change just a little bit but we have multiple people
our family personally that have high sensitivity to gluten but they can eat chemit flour
bread and chemit flour everything so this is an ancient grade it's got it's you know one of the
theories about gluten sensitivity has to do with the fact that we processed the wheat and
hybridized it and it's a way that it's really not the same as an ancient grade
but if we get back to the ancient grades it would make a big difference so I would investigate that
as well. Hi doc GR a chemo 2 and a half years ago I'm not really sure what this means here but chemo
2 and a half years ago but the last six months the neuropathy in my feet legs and above these left
finger and arm it is slowly getting worse and painful I'm taking B12 and nutritional yeast what else
can I do. We talked about neuropathy above there think about getting a rebuilder
make sure that you're doing the iron crow wave help detox the chemo therapy the vitamin B6 is
really helpful for healthy rebuilders too so that is a good thing to add and most of those of the
those would be the key things right there you know iron crow waves help detox that make sure you're
with as long as we're talking about detox iron crow wave you also got to you got to talk about
the property animals so I don't know if you've stopped doing that or you're still doing those
um uh sawdaz can be very helpful for detoxification go back and hey you have access to the
seven phases of detox course right there look at that um that will be helpful for you
vitamin B6 is helpful for rebuilding herbs with uh with their opathy so make sure that you have
adequate vitamin B6 taking a little bit of extra B6 I have begun taking my new supplements for the
last cheek swab unfortunately related or not fluid started building up in my abdomen which I had
to have expelled at the hospital uh the doctor said the fluid was from the cancer uh so yes I would
agree so the fluid is this when you get a sighties in any cavity whether it's in
burrow cavity or the abdominal cavity it's from a cancer there's only theories on why that happens
there's no definitive answer from why that happens the addition I could not irritate my bladder was
also emptied at the hospital I continue to have a hard time irritate you you don't have to go back to
the hospital for a long-term stint is there anything I can do to help with urination it's
insured by having to stop for a lot to begin with fluid but there's nothing you can do to you know
to ensure that your abdomen will fill with fluid I would say number one do not wait until it gets
bad get in there more often than not um because getting that drained we've had people you know have
you know get you know five to seven liters drained off you know every three days and you take
oh is this the end no they're still with us today they recovered so don't think that at all
but do not go well I will okay I'll be fine I'll just you know hold off for another week don't do
that get in you're better off getting into the ER getting that drained off more often than not
more often than less often so get in there as soon as you start to get some fluid accumulation
number two if it's starting to block your urine flow that gets dangerous because you get back up
into your kidney and you can get damaged to the kidneys that's irreversible so you do not want to let
that happen if the urine blockage and it sounds like the urine blockage is due to the fluid
putting pressure on either the urethra or one of the ureters and if that's the case then it's
really removing the fluid to deal with the urination issue if you have if the if the inflammation is
also caused this is a male I believe that asks this question to have the inflammation is also
caused prosthetic you know morbidity of a prosthetic hypertrophy at the same time and getting
on some prostate nutrients can be helpful that but I don't know if I'm just guessing at that it
sounds though that that it is a physical pressure on the urethra or the ureter that's
causing that now you can help with that with it's a physical pressure by getting by changing
positions the worst thing you could do if it's a physical pressure putting the the fluid just
pressured on the urethra is laid on your back so you know get down on all fours like in a crawled
position like you're in a crawled just relax your tummy and try to just relax your abdominal
muscles so the fluid will settle down gravity will help pull it down towards the floor that will help
take some pressure can help take some pressure off through your ureter and see if they tell
ways to see pregnant women that that pressure and the baby can put pressure on your organs and
doing that can help take pressure off that's what other thing you can do
writing some frequencies for bladder infections making sure you don't have a concurrent bladder
infection can be beneficial I don't know if in the hospital they did a urine analysis but you
should ask for that next time you go in just to the routine UA to make sure there's not bacteria
in your urine that's present because you could have a bladder infection as well and you want to
address that so make sure you don't who that is and you know rough it out like a man you've got to
make sure you deal with that go down don't over with us because you've got a lot of serious problems
I was told that very high over 60 milligrams of melatonin can fight against cancer
is that high about effective so yes it's anywhere between 40 and 200 milligrams of melatonin
that could be another thing against cancer that's hard to fight a melatonin supplement that's
that high we have one for ballergy research there's 20 milligrams so they're small capsules so you
can take three of them to get 60 both people take anywhere between 60 a hundred and 40 milligrams
I have one person that thinks taking 200 milligrams melatonin but average is between 60 and 140 my
doctor is not familiar with that bend is all and tell me it's not good for the liver since that
remark I have been gunshot giving it to a husband at the beginning I put it into shakes but he's
doctor it can shake so I used to mix it in with water and put it directly in the feeding tube my
question to your knowledge have you heard about this doing something to the liver okay you're
taking if you're taking a pack of the bend is all which is equivalent to what you'd give a 10-pound
dog and I don't think you have to worry about any liver toxicity I find this funny to hear this
from a doctor who readily hands out lipitor like we talked about before like it's Easter candy and
pressures and guilt people into doing people therapy that could kill a person and they say that
they want a bend is all that could give a 10-pound dog giving to a 150-pound person is dangerous to your
liver I am sorry we'll fill it's on that also if I start the bend is all isn't more effective with
the whole geotipin's protocol or is it better take it alone it's better with the whole protocol but
when you're out of feed too you have to cut a middle of the eyes what you can possibly give a person
I got an impingement of a rotator cop that they think was at least based on normal exercise
and that's no fun let's have for my daughter last this weekend she
long off the earth horse and landed wrong and hurt her rotator cop saw the ortho he ordered a MRI
in my shoulder arm when he feels with all my mobility maybe a picture paid has been a 10 for the last
seven days with sleepless nights sorry about that I've had no choice to start predisone
pack for 12 days as I tried everything else for the pain with the lock tried PT yesterday
paid was a barrel yeah don't go to PT don't let any physical doctor a chiropractor try
to manipulate your shoulder it was just to get on here I thought it all set up last time when I
listened to it you want it to heal so don't don't do that and bummed about taking a supplements that
predisone is it would be a kind of blocker so yeah but you've got to do what you've got to do
I would I would also run okay I had this happen to be oh gosh it was about you know it was
had to be like eight or nine years ago no I'll tell you lies and I was in a sling for three weeks
I literally if I moved my arm totally out I got a shot I was taking a Tylenol and you understand
I could buy a bottle of Tylenol and it lasts me about 10 years so I just don't take this stuff
so this is before my cancer diagnosis and I heard it lifted weights or something like that and I was
in pain just horrible I was in a sling slept with a sling I could not move my arm was just my left
shoulder and then finally ran a program on the right called accelerated healing
it's in the folder called the normalizing frequency folder so the normalizing
sorry I have to look at the key the next time so it's in the normalizing frequency folder
accelerated healing I'm gonna say this is gonna work for you because it's just it's frequencies
but I tell you I did that one time and that I literally forgot to take my my Tylenol at three
hours and it's like it was like six hours later like oh I didn't take my Tylenol I tried and
clocked oh my gosh it's like okay it doesn't hurt I moved it even with a sling it it's not hurting
not hurting uh I went home from work that day and I was literally afraid to take the I still didn't
take the sling off because it's like no way I'm not gonna take it off this is just gonna
won't send me through the room literally I did the accelerated healing I think three or four more
times and my shoulder you know healed up I'd ever had that zinger paid anymore my pain went down
to zero I mean I had some pain as I was trying to I had this stuck in a position
that's very weak so it took some little bit of exercise to get it back to normal motion it took
a few weeks but it was it was quite amazing also think about the tens unit so whatever you get musculoskeletal
pain like this a tens unit is a nice little addition you I wouldn't necessarily do it right over a
possible damaged ligament but I would do it where my pain is and it can really help with the pain
is there a specific tumor marker for a suffered geol cancer if yes what would be the
raging numbers we spoke to our internist about laser surgery for the esophagus he said
it would not get rid of the cancer but would improve the esophagus for eating solids he did not
know of any laser surgeons for that part of the body do you know of any specific laser surgeons
so I don't know of any specific laser surgeons you might have to continue to seek
you know some advice from medical impressions for that there is no specific tumor marker for
a suffered geol cancer you could run a tumor marker panel and any of them might show up but there's
none that are specific for that cancer does anyone do blood transfusions with blood from someone
who is beaten ovarian cancer no that does not happen that wouldn't be legally in the United States
and if the idea I think this person is getting at is that if somebody beat a specific type of cancer would
there be any um chemicals chemo kinds in the blood antibodies in the blood that would help
another person with that same type of cancer well your body doesn't kill cancer by developing antibodies
to the cancer so that wouldn't be a factor at all but only there'd be I think there'd be zero benefit
to get to receive blood from somebody who had a disease like ovarian cancer and overcame it
if you got blood from somebody that had an overcame like let's say a bacterial infection
and you received their blood you'd be receiving possible antibodies to that bacteria but not to
cancer okay questions came in here neuropathy is getting worse over the last three months have had
lots of symptoms I used the rebuild here and it's not working for me very much what else could I do so
I think I addressed that on this question of the things that you want to do with neuropathy you have
to do a lot of things with neuropathy you got to understand that your nerves grow back very slowly
so you have to give your three months it's not enough time to even assess whether you know
anything you're doing is working so and you please do watch the video on our store
go to our store and if you didn't get the rebuilder from us go to the store look up rebuilder
and watch the video that I created um actually created it for practitioners
on um the appherent your pathways and what I actually take you place
I have a new paedranic enzyme supplement that has these amounts of each in the how many capsules should I
take AM and PM um it's it I don't know what I've recommended for you if you're asking this like
that you're trying to do a paedranic um meeting a um enzyme therapy like Dr. Kelly's
enzyme therapy um you're still taking you still be taking a lot for a capsule and I'd have to
sit down and do the math prepared to be recommended so you can't really answer that question off the back
sorry about that any good resources for a plant-based keto diet so
well I would just go to search it on my computer um I don't go off stop my hand I apologize
the lipozole glutecler says on your store that I will need to get you to
that I need to get do a half to wait time before meals or after or could I just take it any time
as you said three teaspoons a day so can you take glutecyle with a meal yeah you can
I do think that the lipozole moles do work better a little bit away from food about 15 to 30 minutes
away from food would be better you'll have better absorption of a lipozole so that's the whole idea
why you're taking a lipozole moles for better absorption so I just wait 15 to 30 minutes away from food
should I be doing the right programs and put back duried radiation treatments uh yes absolutely yes
I finished by 8th of 20 treatments at two grade today I have done two copy animals in the past two
weeks you're about to get more than one a week well we have a lot of people that are doing two copy
animals a day so well you're only doing one copy animal a week you're not you know you're getting
some benefit of parasympathetic stimulation and helping with liver detoxification helping with
immune stimulation but if you really want to get the benefits of copy animals you've got to really
bump it up to you know really want it a day I mean Dr. Gerson used to have people do if they were
doing something like this going through radiation or chemo there but we keep them through
anywhere up to five per day so if you got to think about hopefully that out what program on the
iAid bowway for chemo I would do the detox it's called clearline detox I would do the clearline detox
yeah here it is detox clearline that's what I would do I get my last trade for out tomorrow when could I
start copy animals again is it okay to lay on my side you know you'll have to see how you're healing
there remember you know doing copy animals doing it you know following it by the Gerson book of
laying on your side and doing all that I guess that's best I'll be honest that's why I put up the
easy peasy way of doing copy animals I never did that so I think if you're getting enough fluid
in you're going to be stimulating the vagal nerve alongside your um in your rectum and that's not
going to be an issue this late on your side so you could even do it standing so I'd say we'd
start it right away I know from genetics I have a problem making glutathione any problems you see
with debilized glutathione no not at all so maybe we talked about that three weeks ago on the zoo
you know we see a lot of autoimmune patients in our office where we saw people in the office
packed of early 2000s and such after I wrote my book on autoimmune disease and it was um uh
uh and that we did debilized glutathione and everybody so that was prior to the acetyl glutathione
coming out so understand there's several forms of glutathione out there and they've
progressed in their um in their quality over the years so in the late 1990s to early 2000s
there was a form of glutathione that wasn't really well absorbed at all and and taking it you know
was kind of beautiful so uh debilizing it worked pretty well so we used that form in a debilized form
uh or we just dissolved it in fluid either water or fluid or silver and then debilized it and people
would just stay there so that they're with a debilizer and breathe that in for 10 to 15 minutes
very beneficial then they came out the acetyl glutathione and the acetyl glutathione is
much better absorbed and that was a huge hit in the natural community because you could actually
absorb glutathione. I understand glutathione is recycled in your cell and it's through the
system pathways and from a genetic standpoint that that function takes place um then and just about
five years ago or so and they came out with like a zonal glutathione, holy cow, total gain change
you're there so like a zonal glutathione is you know ten times better absorbed um and remember
glutathione is your number one antioxidant and remember what does an antioxidant do an antioxidant
helps get rid of oxidizing agents if you don't get rid of oxidizing agents you're dead tomorrow
period oxidizing agents are poisoned oxidizing agents are your number one closet cancer period so
we talk about oh toxins are what toxins are number one closet cancer because they're oxidizing agents
so oxidizing agents damage cell membranes kill cells who sell through lysis uh damage DNA you're
better off but kill kill the cell um because the damage is DNA and it causes cancer so you have to get rid
of uh oxidizing agents glutathione is your number one way to do that in trust cellularly
uh we have different pathways in phase one phase two pathways which do sell in your liver even though
glutathione is your liver glutathione it's the cellularly you know outside salimated in your tissues
is your number one way to do that and you need your recycling you need to support that recycling and if
you have defects on that it's even more difficult so taking liposomal glutathione is great second best
thing would be to stabilize glutathione okay left side and vagal nerve stimulation cause shoulder
issues and nerves around that no no can left side vagus nerve stimulation cause shoulder issues
no so the vagus nerve would if you stimulate the vagus nerve you're actually going to decrease pain
so that a huge amount of pain um in inhibition through the vagal nerve but there's some
um uh there's some good i should say that there's more better than some to the vagus nerves
it's made purposes doctor inhibit pain but it doesn't give it pain uh so yeah no i don't think
that's going to be an issue and so i have neuropathy in my left leg from the chemotherapy
besides some of the things you've already discussed which i do the doctor has me on lasex with a
fluid is there anything else i could do that is natural uh well lasex there's nothing you're
going to do naturally that's going to get rid of fluid like lasex we do have a um a folio pathic
dropper a diuretic folio pathic dropper um and some people have said that that's helped
um you do want to assess your diet a little bit because if you are retaining fluid only on one side
let's say if it's only mainly on your left side then you then you have to address the
for sure fact that you have some blockage in flow of the lymph there if you have
retaining fluid in both of your lower extremities um you have to address the possibility of lymph
issues um so looking at lymphatic detoxification i think we have some stuff on our blog on lymphatic
detoxification you can google lymphatic detoxification different exercise for lymphatic detoxification
that would help but as far as the substitute for lasex i don't think there's any natural substitute
lasex i mean that's going to do the same thing as that um but there is a we do have a diuretic that is
that's a folio path that we've had some people say it really helps so when you see day DNA repair
frequency where should the ball be on the body typically you'd put it right in your belly
so that it's going to be center so that it's going to hit majority of your body is it true that cancer
cells will use glutathione for their own benefit well yes they will so cancer cells will use
gluten any cells so cancer cell member is just drilled cell that is rapidly replicating that it's
going to need a lot of glutathione so yes it will use glutathione for its own benefit um and there
you know i've taken the position at different times throughout my career that maybe a cancer patient
shouldn't be on a lot of glutathione but i've kind of reversed that decision based on new
information that has come out that is more beneficial to decrease the oxidizing agents in your healthy
cells i don't know that cancer cells uptake glutathione very well um just like they don't uptake any
nutrition very well that's why most cancer cells go and start reproducing you know fermented state
through um what is known as a warberg effect because the the waste that is around the
growing cancer doesn't allow um for um oxygen to be transported very well to it so it ends up being
in a hypoxic warberg effect so no i don't think that that's an issue maybe other questions
okay do you remember when they get into some more of the protagonists go on to the
course and remember to use your save user david password as you've good to get out of the member site
and you have access to all those courses so all right thanks for being on know that i pray it for
all you guys i love you all and we'll see you next week bye bye